They said humans to walk on the moon
flew by every single planet in our solar
system and delivered the first residents
to the international space station.
What else could NASA have done
if it had a bigger budget,
say the budget of the u s military,
how close would we be to colonizing Mars?
Would you be spending
your vacation on the moon?
What about visiting other solar systems?
This is what f and here's what would
happen if NASA had the u s military budget
in 1969 NASA spent over $25 billion or
about 170 billion in today's money so
that the whole world could see this.
But once a small step for man
became one giant leap for mankind,
the budget of the American led space
agency started shrinking. Today,
NASA gets less than $20 billion annually
to explore and colonize what's out
there.
Is that enough for humanities ambitions?
Not if you plan on buying a
piece of land on the moon.
What if due to a printing
error in the federal budget,
all the money destined for the u s
military went to the space agency instead,
what would $600 billion pay for?
Here's the International Space Station,
the largest artificial satellite that's
ever orbited earth over 200 people have
lived and worked here since it launched
in 1998 but it may be defended as of
2024 and then no one's going to set
foot on it with another hundred billion
dollars.
NASA could afford to keep
doing the research on the
ISS for at least another 20
years. Uh, military size
budget would cover that.
Not only would it allow the space
station to remain up and running,
but it would also allow them to send more
astronauts and there'd still be enough
money leftover for NASA.
Biggest ongoing projects developing the
space launch system that would carry us
to the moon and deep space,
not a problem.
And then there's Mars
together with space X.
Nasa could restore the UNHCR ood red
dragon mission that would mark the
beginning of Mars colonization.
Sending the first humans to Mars would
cost NASA around $450 billion with $600
billion of annual funding accrued mission
to the Red Planet would become NASA as
next Apollo. Very quickly, we
build a human colony on the moon,
turning it into a base for
our trips into deep space.
It would so serve as a
blueprint for Mars colonization.
We'd move up the launch date on the
Europa Clipper, a mission to Jupiter,
smallest moon in search of signs of
alien life in the oceans of liquid water
beneath its icy shell.
Maybe Europa would become our next
destination for the crude missions.
Just imagine regular commercial space
flight unscrewed missions to other solar
systems,
increasing biological and physiological
studies to figure out how humans can
survive away from Earth.
Wouldn't that be awesome?
What else do you think we can
achieve with a military budget?